(gentle music)
- Hello?
- Hello.
- Hello. Oh, wow.
It's weird.
(Sophia laughs)
Cause I can't hear, I can.
I kind of can barely hear my own voice.
- The same.
- So it's like, am I shouting?
Oh God, how loud am I?
- You're actually not loud at all.
You sound great. Like.
- oh my God.
You sound the same.
- How cool is this?
It's like the tiniest microphone.
- Yeah.
- And we're like sitting outside
and we can't hear really anything outside
but I just hear your voice really great.
That's amazing.
- Also we can like look
at the opposite direction
from six feet away.
- Yeah.
And it feels like I'm looking at you.
That's so weird.
- Oh, man.
- It's everything. This is so cool.
- Well, hi, I'm Ryan.
- I'm Sophia.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, Sophia.
- Hi.
- What's, uh, what's your name?
- My name is Ranya.
- Ranya.
- What's yours?
- My name is Alexa.
- Alexa. Nice to meet you.
- Yeah, it is nice to meet you too.
- Um, shoot. It's like that hard part
of like introducing
yourself where you just like
- Like what do we talk about?
- Yeah.
- Like, like, I don't know.
But I struggle with like
- Well, here's a question.
Are you from San Diego, Ryan?
- Um, I was born here and then
I lived in Escondido for a while.
- Okay.
- Are you from San Diego?
- I am not. I am from Los Angeles.
- Oh. Where at?
- I'm from South Central LA.
- Oh, Cool.
So like the inner city.
The cut cut.
(Sophia laughs)
- Oh, all right.
All right.
- Did you travel here with anyone?
- No. I'm here by myself.
- Awesome.
It's a little solo trip.
- That's so great.
I love that.
- How are you doing really?
- How am I doing, really?
Oh man.
Wowser Bowser.
Oh, oh, that's really it's.
Oh God
- Hard. It's a hard question.
- It's really hard.
- It's a very hard question.
- It's really hard
And you know, you only get as personal
as you wanna get and,
you just met me.
- Yeah
- I'm gonna say as a stranger, I love you.
And this is an open
space and like, you know.
- Aww...
- I'm a shoulder, I'm an ear.
- Okay
- And if, if you don't
need a shoulder and ear
I'm still a shoulder and an ear.
- All right, all right, all right.
Well you, you said so,
you opened the door.
- I'm opening it.
- I've been trying to like
figure stuff out between me
and a friend, you know, as
a past like romantic thing.
And it's been like weighing
on me cause I don't know how
to like express myself, you
know, accurately in the moment.
So that's kind of why I
came here today was to
like walk around and see things.
Cause like, like you were
saying about all the nature
and stuff, but there's
so many people here.
- Absolutely. Yeah.
- So like I get the like, I don't know.
Like I love watching the
little kids run around.
- Yeah.
- Of like throwing, I don't know.
- It's a positive place.
It changes your perspective.
You see, you know, you people watch
you see like, you know,
other healthy friendships
and relationships and it's
like a happy place, you know?
And it, I, I can see how it makes you feel
like you're gonna be there
and you're gonna get there and you will.
- Yeah
- And so if you need some encouragement
on that note, you will, you'll get there.
And if like it's somebody that like
isn't like reciprocating,
how you feel about them.
I would leave that where it is.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- Like love them from a distance kind of.
I kind of, I'm trying
to hit that stage where
I at least... like say
what I mean, you know
instead of just like getting
scared, getting real close
to it and then seeing
that I'm about to say it
and then like losing it,
you know what I mean?
- Right.
- And then going, like
being dissatisfied afterward
going like, at least
if I said the stuff...
- Right.
- Then I don't know.
I could feel better about it.
- Yeah. Get it off your chest.
Say like what you need to say
and like leave it where it is from there.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah
- Like if it's not a reciprocation of love
if it's not like a reciprocation of energy
I would leave it where it is, You know?
Because like seriously, if
there's anything we've realized
with everything we've been going through
its life is too short.
It's just too short.
(Ryan laughs)
- Yeah. No, you're you hella, right.
- It is. It's too short
- I'm doing good. I
really do love my life.
I feel like I have so many
good people in my world
and I get to see so many pretty things.
But my like next six months
have just a ton of uncertainty
and it's definitely something
I like think about and
like stress about every day.
I'm like, where am I gonna live?
What am I gonna be doing?
What unit am I gonna be working on?
Like, I need to get a job.
There's a lot of uncertainty.
But I also feel very lucky
to have so many options.
The options are
overwhelming, but it's cool
that I get to decide
between so many things.
- That's awesome.
- How are you really doing?
- Ah!.
(Laughs nervously)
- Right. I know.
- Why do you have to ask me back?
(Both laugh)
- So I'm, I've been having
some issues with my mom.
I love her to death.
We run a company together,
and I have not been in the
state that run our affairs in.
And so she like rent
my place out to Airbnb.
- Wow.
- And I have been very upset about it.
And I've been like to the
point where I've called my mom
her physical legal name, like.
- All four names, all three names
- Her whole name.
And I she's only been
mom to me before that.
- Oh wow.
- She was like, she
repeated her name back.
And she was like, you know, like, Laura
like that's not her name.
But she was like, oh, you're
gonna call me my name back.
(Sophia laughs)
- Wow.
- I don't understand why
we're in the place we're in
when I'm trying and I'm working
hard and I'm finally getting
to a place in my life
where I'm really trying.
And I'm really working hard.
- Yo, same.
I like it's also like asserting yourself
like by saying her full
name, like saying that like
this is not like a one
sided relationship anymore.
- Yeah.
- You know.
- I'm an adult too.
And like, we're gonna, you know
we're gonna treat each other as such.
- I have a lot of the same
like hangups with my mom where
you know, we don't really
talk that much anymore.
And it's cause it really
like (muted) me up for a
couple of days afterward.
- I'm so sorry.
- No it's cool.
You know, you didn't do it
- My mom's amazing. But
I'm so sorry about that.
- No, she's, like that's the thing is like
my mom is great and like, you
know, I don't know, but it's.
- Our moms are great.
We just wanna put that out there.
- Yeah. No moms are great.
Moms are always cool, but
this like, I don't know
balancing like what they want from you
from what you want from yourself
and like saying that (muted)
that's (muted) hard at
the dinner table, man.
- Very hard.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, for so long you live
in their shadow and you know
we are kind of like
their hearts walking outside
of them and I get that.
- Yeah. Wow.
But it's, I think it's just
really hard for them to see us
as our own people for a lot
of them and to like, you know
give us that respect that we deserve
that we definitely deserve.
- It's like some that she
told my sister, right.
That got back to me that
really bothered me was
that she's waiting for me to fall apart
so that she can take care of me again.
And it's like, are you
expecting me to fail?
Are you wanting me to fail?
- Right.
- Like, like what's going on here, dude?
- It's so bad.
It's just like, you want your kids
for the most part to succeed.
I think in my eyes, like, you know?
- Yeah.
- You want them to do the best, you know?
Like she wants you to be your happiest
but she also wants to
feel needed, you know?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- My mom is Bulgarian.
So I'm gonna just like put that out there.
I don't know like how much
you know about like Bulgarians
but they are very overbearing people.
They're very loving people
but I think any foreign
parent is gonna be like that.
But I think any parent
in general, even American
or otherwise is also gonna
be, you know, very overbearing
very like thumb on your
head, kind of, you know
it was like,
I couldn't really move without
her saying, so, you know
you jump when I say, so, you know,
you sleep when I say, so
you wake up when I say so.
(Ryan sighs)
And it's just like living in a bubble.
- No same.
- It's hard.
It is very hard.
- When did you realize you
were not like everyone else?
- Oh.
(Both laugh)
- I like this one.
- I okay. Maybe at the end
of the end of high school
like I got through high
school, but I don't know.
I feel like I wasn't really myself
in high school just cause I don't know.
Like I, a black Muslim
woman, child of immigrants,
I was struggling with my identities then.
And then after I graduated high school
and I was about to start college
it was kind of that
transitional period of my life.
And I'm like, okay, who am I?
Who do I wanna be?
And that's kind of when I
started wearing my hijab
cause I wanted to own
my Muslim identity more.
But yeah, I think that
summer was probably a
very very telling time for me.
Just because I realized
that who I was in high school,
wasn't who I wanted to be.
And it wasn't really me.
And now that I'm more
comfortable with who I am, I feel
like I get to explore and do
more things that make me happy.
- That's amazing.
What a great story.
(Ranya laughs)
- What about you?
- Probably this summer maybe,
actually I had like just a lot
of friends around me telling me
about like the impact that I had made
in their life and it
made me feel really good.
And I, like realized
that I had the ability to like bring light
into people's lives, who
like were maybe lacking that a bit.
And that makes me feel special.
- That's amazing.
- All right, now I gotta ask you,
what's something I would
not believe about you.
(Sophia laughs)
- Believe about me.
Believe about me.
Oh man.
If I gotta think about
what you think about me
and then when I think about
you thinking about me.
- It's kind of weird because
as a stranger, it's like
I could think of you doing anything
- Right? No. Yeah. It's the infinite void.
Holy cannoli.
You know what, here's one.
I do. I struggle meeting people.
(both laugh)
Like I really, I'm really.
- Oh yeah.
You've been very natural in
this stranger conversation.
Not seeing your face at all.
- Yeah.
- Like, wow.
Okay. I would not believe
that. Okay. That's fair.
- It's like understanding
where the boundaries are.
Like I don't want to make
people feel uncomfortable
you know?
And it's like, I don't
know how to explain myself.
You know?
I, I don't know.
It's about like the
situations, like I work
at a gas station, right.
I'm alone.
And I work at a gas station
and I get to have like
300 little conversations
with people a day.
So I'm getting better at this.
(Sophia laughs)
But it's like, all right, seeing a person
with a cool thing on their
shirt and saying like,
Hey that's a cool thing.
What's that about?
Like make, is that gonna
make that person feel weird?
Or is that person gonna
go like, oh no, cool.
I really like sunflowers.
Outside of me being
behind a cash register.
I don't really know how
to start those things.
You know?
I don't know how to like walk
up to people cause it's like
why would they look, why
would they talk to me?
Right. I should just
like leave them alone.
They're having a nice
little life over there.
I don't know.
So I just, I just keep to
myself and that's pretty safe,
but, you know.
- You know, I hear you, I hear you.
That's a safe place to stay.
- Yeah. I know. I dunno.
- But branch out because
you're not awkward.
You like, you've seem
like very like open and
very sweet, very genuine.
And so like,
I feel like you're the
only one holding you back,
kind of in this like situation.
Right? It's like you feel more awkward
than you need to feel kind
of about like meeting folks.
Like, you know
everybody feels awkward about
meeting new people, right?
- Yeah.
- So just get out there and do it.
- No, thank you.
That's a good, I didn't.
- You're welcome.
- That's a good sentence right there.
(Sophia laughs)
- What has been the moment
you felt the most alive?
- Oh, I love that.
- Me too, I like this question
- I feel really alive
when I'm outside and when
I'm like in the mountains
preferably on top of
a mountain and I just,
and the sun are coming down
on me and I'm just like, yep.
This is it.
- I like that. I have the same answer.
I just like love being in the mountains.
But if I'm talking about
like a specific moment
I think last summer I
hiked Cold Chuck Lake.
I don't know if you're familiar with that.
(Alexa gasps)
- I've done it.
- Oh my God.
That is my favorite hike to date.
Just all the moments from the hike.
Like just the struggle getting
up there, cause it was a
it was an intense hike.
- so intense.
- And then like all the
strangers convincing me
and my friends to jump in.
I think like that's
probably my favorite moment.
And that just happened
like last year or yeah, in the summer.
- Awesome.
- Think it's interesting
that I can't see you
until I get up and turn
around, that's cool.
That that's an interesting thing.
- No, it's it's like you're
you're a Bulgarian from south central.
(Sophia laughs)
- Two of the weirdest things
that ever said in a sentence.
- No. Yeah.
You're like what was the
potato soup like in your house?
(Sophia laughs and claps)
Was it like, well, spiced,
you know, I wanna know.
- Absolutely. You can
say we've had the best
the best of the best. This is how we eat
- It's like, my family didn't cook a lot.
Like you know, like they tried but.
- I'm sorry.
- Ooowee.
It was a lot of like TV
trays and stuff, you know?
- And the freaking hamburger helper.
- Yeah. Oh my God.
(Sophia laughs)
Not that not even on that level.
I wish I'm a, I love like,
like Mexican and Latin
cuisines and all that stuff.
- I love to cook. Same, same.
- What's what's your
favorite thing to cook
for people when they come over?
- Ooh. Probably something stuffed
so like a stuffed pepper
or like a stuffed squash.
- Oh man.
That's a lot of work.
- It's delicious.
- That, that sounds good.
(Sophia laughs)
- Oh.
- Yes
- Now mine is, oh man, this is on YouTube.
So I better pronounce it right.
"Arroz con pollo".
- Oh, you did. That was a good job,
you pronounced that right.
- There you go.
I tried, everybody loves rice and chicken.
- Yeah. Who doesn't wanna get together
for some rice and chicken?
- Yeah. Hell yeah.
You put it, make burritos the next day.
- Speaking my "lengua",
speaking my "lengua".
- Oh, "lengua". Yeah. I love "lengua".
Holy cannoli.
- Oh me too.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Seriously at the right taco truck,
you can just go to heaven
- Yeah.
- like on a, you know,
a nice juicy tortilla,
with like some lettuce and like some guac.
- Oh man.
- If you wanna really
get the best you drive
across the border and
it's like no big deal
but everybody's like
so scared unless you're
like native and then, you
know, like it's all good.
Mexico's a great place. Stop being scared.
- Dude. You, oh.
I've been trying to practice my Spanish
so I can go over there.
Cause it's like something
a little daunting about
being over there alone.
I don't have anybody to
come with me, but you know
- Yes. It's true.
A little alone is kind of scary.
I'll go with you.
I'll be your buddy.
(Sophia laughs)
- Let's go to, I was gonna
I was looking at tickets
for like a soccer game.
- Okay. Well I would like to say
that I think you are a very warm person
from just talking to you in
this short amount of time
not knowing you beforehand
or seeing you at all.
I feel like you're a very warm
and open person and genuine
person and I'm happy.
I got to spend some time
sitting here talking to you.
- Well, thank you.
- I like the things
that you value, you know
- Thank you.
- Like some things that you've said
of like, like family, like connection.
- Thank you.
- You know, honesty
like a purpose, you know
I think it's really cool
that you're like aware that
caring is important and cool.
- Amen.
- That's that's pretty nice dude.
- And people care about
you and Jesus loves you.
- God bless.
(Sophia blows a kiss)
- Your story about how you
like found like yourself
and faced that challenge
was really inspiring to me.
- Thank you.
- Yeah. Yeah. And like started
to wear your like hijab
and like that's really cool.
- Thank you, thank you.
I feel like you're gonna
be an amazing nurse.
You seem like a kind soul.
You'll be a great nurse.
Just keep going through with it
and hopefully you'll be done soon.
- Thank you.
(gentle music)
- Hi.
- You're so pretty!
(both laugh)
- Wow, I could not even picture someone
but it's nice to meet you.
- I know. It's nice to meet you too.
I liked talking with you.
- Me too.
Are you here by yourself or (indistinct)
- Hello!
It was nice meeting you. This was fun.
I was so scared when she said this.
I was like, I don't know.
I was a little nervous.
I was like, am I gonna meet her?
- I'm glad that you did it.
And I'm glad you on this vacation alone.
- Thank you, Thank you.
- Oh hey. Hey. Nice to meet you, dude.
(Sophia laughs)
- Nice to meet you.
- How you doing?
Oh man, Holy cannoli.
- Nice to meet you.
- That's so weird. Yeah. Golly G
- Hey everyone, Thoraya here.
I wanted to say thank you
for watching this episode.
I am still selling these
sweaters on my website.
If you're interested.
I'll link it in my description.
I love you guys.
And I'll see you next week.